I'll put some music on it thank you to
MU B for sponsoring this video one of
the things I absolutely love about the
Coen brothers is their knack for
creating vibrant and interesting minor
characters with Cincinnati Cincinnati
it's not in here
their main characters are wonderfully
realized but often play a sort of
straight man to a world filled with
wacky and unique individuals sorry if
you'd like to kiss him it would be
alright thank you the spirit has flown
your wire said $50 you didn't see Benny
bambam before he was shot across Oh No
the characters that surround the main
characters often found behind a desk can
I share something with you Lydia's mom
what'd you do I know this kind of man
yet older skin in here or a counter if
you don't want to accept that I don't
know what else I'm gonna do for me
welcome to Los Angeles mr. Fink watch
your language young fella I'm just one
person so don't matter the size of the
bed these minor characters are only
minor in the amount of screen time they
receive my god my dogs are barking we
started out at this little place right
off of Wilshire and quite beautiful in a
lot of films the minor characters that
surround the main characters are either
non-existent or a bland afterthought but
in a Coen Brothers film the minor
characters can be just as interesting as
the protagonists and villains the Coen
brothers ability to quickly create
interesting characters with a short
amount of screen time is a critical
element of their latest film The Ballad
of Buster Scruggs where the anthology
format guarantees almost every character
will only have a short time to be
developed on screen and yet in the short
moments many of these characters have on
screen
I found myself more invested in them
that I often end
main characters that inhabit a lot of
feature-length films these types of
minor characters are non-existent in
their first film Blood Simple but we'll
start to see examples pop up in their
second film raising Arizona
well which is it young feller you want
I've said freeze or get down on the
ground and their use of minor characters
has gradually increased throughout their
filmography the brothers want these
characters to immediately stand out and
make a strong first impression and there
are a lot of ways they do this they'll
use exaggerated costumes well ma bear
skin or mannerisms an obvious mood
they'll introduce the character on
screen in an unusual way and sometimes
use small details like the dirt around
the character's fingernail welcome to
the hotel may I help you sir sometimes
it's the posture of the character what's
the rumpus or their accent oh yeah no no
no mostly pretty good and even kids
oh so you think I'm some kind of jerk
for asking only you don't use the word
jerk or the way the protagonist reacts
the first time they see the character or
talks about them when they're not
on-screen her wants to see me and the
Cohens are not afraid to let these
characters momentarily take center stage
and to the Dame there's one in every
story ten bucks says she's looking for a
handout well what about those our reps
are all up there are two ways the
brothers use casting to help minor
characters stand out the first is by
using relatively unknown actors that
have an interesting look and these
people catch our attention at first
glance the Coen brothers have been known
to put out casting calls for regular
looking people and they're often looking
for the types that are the opposite of
extras that just blend into
background long-term parking charges by
the day the second way they used casting
when they've employed more often in
recent movies like Hail Caesar is using
a relatively well-known actor for a
fairly minor role a great example of
this is Jonah Hill's character in Hail
Caesar who appears on screen for all of
a minute and 40 seconds as part of the
job but examples of this go as far back
as raising Arizona where they used
Emmett Wolff for only two scenes perhaps
most importantly these minor characters
stand out because they aren't just
filler the rabbi is busy they often have
something the protagonist once I don't
see a lot of money here or are thwarting
the protagonists goals
I will pay two hundred and twenty five
dollars and keep the gray horse I don't
want the Pope there will be no
settlement after I leave this office it
will go to law they create obstacles for
the protagonist now we got a nice quiet
little beach community here and I aim to
keep it nice and quiet or are an
obstacle their presence has a real
effect on the protagonist the God is
working in shoes which makes them an
important and memorable part of the
world what are you nuts
there's a certain amount of subtlety and
slower pacing that's usually effective
for developing a main character however
when trying to quickly create a
memorable minor character there's often
not enough time to be subtle about
things the Coen brothers are a lot of
things but subtle is not one of the
words I would use to describe most of
their filmmaking the over-the-top and
exaggerated style they've perfected for
their comedy films makes them
well-suited to create these characters
quickly hiya buddy my name's buzz I got
the fuzz I make the elevator do what she
does but they've also learned to apply
some of those techniques more subtly in
their dramatic films three years ago I
said then Barry
no and good having these vibrant minor
characters in a film makes the world of
the film feel larger and more expansive
finally got I got the venue I wanted I'm
performing my dance quintet you know my
cycle it makes the audience feel like
the place the protagonist inhabits is
living and breathing and larger than
just the main character the clone
brothers obviously care about these
characters and put just as much effort
into writing directing and casting them
as they do their main characters and I
think it pays off of course a lot of
credit goes to the individual actors
that play these wonderful supporting
roles so well but the Coen brothers
attention to detail and willingness to
be a little over the top is what has led
them to create some of the most
memorable minor characters we've ever
seen in film
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Commission whiskers thank you - movie
for sponsoring this video movie is a
cinema streaming and download service
with a heavy emphasis on curation it's
available globally there are no ads ever
they have 30 movies available in their
library that you can stream or download
and every day one gets added and one
gets taken away it's a great way to find
new interesting stuff to watch and
explore new corners of cinema if you
know someone who's a cinephile or film
lover movie makes a great gift and when
you give a year you get a month free for
yourself but even if you're not giving
it as a gift get your 30 day free trial
today at MU b.com / thomas flight
that's mu bi comm / thomas flight thank
you so much for watching huge thank you
especially to my patrons go to
patreon.com slash thomas flight to learn
about how you can support the content i
make on this channel and get a few cool
bonus things along the way thanks as
always for watching I hope you have a
great holiday and I will talk to you
again next time
[Music]